good morning john everyone is talking
about student loans incorrectly and it's
making me frustrated so i'm making a
video about some flat decontextualized
numbers for you there's 1.75 trillion
dollars of outstanding student debt in
america held by around 45 million
students that is roughly 39 000 of debt
per student and what you would imagine
given those numbers and what most people
do imagine is the average college
graduate headed out to the workforce
with 39 000 of debt and this is entirely
wrong first let us not forget about the
35 of people who get a degree and do not
have student loans that number was a lot
bigger than i expected it to be and i
think it's important to say that it
exists and that those people have like a
leg up on the 65 percent of the students
who graduate with that second this won't
surprise you but you may not have
noticed it the average student debt
holder didn't just graduate they
graduated a while ago and they have
either been paying down their student
debt or they haven't been in which case
it's actually gone up due to interest so
the 39 thousand dollars isn't what they
come out with it's what is left after
having been paid down so but even
weirder the average student graduating
from a four-year college or university
has about 28 000 of student debt so it
is strange that the average student debt
holder has 39 000 of student debt what's
going on here graduate school is mostly
what's going on here here's the weirdest
plot twist in all of this people who
take out more student loans are less
likely to default on their student loans
much less likely in fact as you take out
more and more student loans you become
less and less likely to default on them
so i guess we figured it out students
just need to take out more student loans
and everything will be better no
something weird is going on here and we
have to figure out what it is what is
the weird thing that's going on well
first people with a lot of student loans
tend to be doctors and lawyers so that's
one bit of this the bigger more
surprising more upsetting reason that
this is the case is that 40 of people
with student loans dropped out without
getting a degree this is a wide variety
of kinds of people but they are more
likely to be black and hispanic they are
more likely to have gone to a high
school in a low-income area they're more
likely to be older when they start
college and they're more likely to be
first-generation students and their
loans tend to be smaller because they
tend to go to cheaper schools for not as
long loan delinquency for this group is
quadruple loan delinquency for people
who graduated now again there are lots
of reasons why people might be in bad
situations with regard to their student
loans and it's often not because they
didn't graduate but this seems like a
cohort that we don't talk about and a
problem that we don't interface with
very much and it is a very big problem
like i'll say it again 40
of people with student loans are not
going to get a degree this all happens
for predictable reasons the biggest one
being financial pressure college doesn't
just cost the money you're spending but
also your near-term lost income which is
vital to many people and the support
that they have to give to their families
and the second biggest cause academic
disqualification is caused by students
not getting a good enough high school
education being under-supported or
over-committed during school there are a
lot of hard parts and failures in higher
education but taking billions and
billions of dollars per year of financed
money from students who aren't going to
end up with a degree like that's
astounding and it is infuriating to me
this is the exact problem that crash
course and arizona state university are
trying to take on with our partnership
providing structures to help students
make good decisions earlier in their
higher education process so they don't
end up making expensive mistakes and
also helping them learn information that
they may not have been taught well in
high school or may have forgotten since
this is a very common outcome at some
schools it is the most common outcome
and i do not understand why we don't
talk about it more because the result of
not talking about it is understanding
the student debt crisis entirely and
correctly when we forgive debt 40 of the
people whose debt is being forgiven are
people who didn't end up with a degree
students that didn't fail but were
failed and on average people who have
debt and no degree have around thirteen
thousand dollars of debt we need to take
on the student loan crisis and we also
need to take on the dropout rate crisis
not just with one-time debt forgiveness
but by supporting students who are
working to make their lives better john
i'll see you on tuesday